foreign
is with us in Toronto Canada hi Mary
welcome to the Ramsay show
hi thanks very much Dave thanks hi
Rachel hello Mary for taking my call
sure how can we help
um
yeah
yeah if you could just want to get some
advice or your advice
and we have a mortgage in first place on
our home and then a line of credit that
we don't have any we haven't taken any
money out but that is in second place as
a mortgage
and we're in a position where we can pay
off that mortgage uh coming up soon but
the advice we were given was that we
should keep that
so we have a mortgage of fourth place
line of credit second place and that
would prevent anyone from fraudulently
putting another mortgage on our home by
keeping that those two first and second
place mortgages on there where did this
advice come from a banker good bank
a banker told you you should stay in
debt what Mary and here's what's sad
this is a particularly ignorant Banker
not only because the advice is ludicrous
but it's asinine let me walk you through
it okay here's the thing let's say you
pay off your house is it different in
Canada let me say this is there any
difference
because she is in Canada so I just want
to throw that out there I I I cannot
imagine that Canadian law allows fraud
okay
no no no no no no no I'm reinsuring
Rachel I'm entering okay so if someone
fraudulently puts debt in your name of
any kind including own your house
it does not stand it gets removed and it
doesn't cost you a thing
you just have to go to the trouble of
removing it
it's not like and having a mortgage on
your house does not protect you
from that
they could still put perspective was his
point
do what
it makes it less attractive for somebody
to pick us up yeah well guess what
mortgage fraud is not rampant
in the U.S or in Canada
it is the most it is the most difficult
kind of fraud to actually accomplish for
a crook it's a lot easier to steal
someone's identity and open up a credit
card like light years easier to open up
a credit card in your name than to do
this and so here's what you ought to do
on the basis of this moron's logic you
should go deeply in debt and stay deeply
in debt all through your life because
then you're less attractive to Identity
thieves
that's how ridiculous this is you know
so no absolutely not
and um by the way don't ask the fox
about the hen house
I'm going to ask a banker if I should
stay in that that's like asking a dog if
it's hungry oh my God a hundred percent
of the time you should stay in debt it's
what I live for is to put people in debt
and keep them in debt that's what Mr
Banker says oh my gosh yeah no darling
no it's amazing they just play on the on
the fear yeah do you know what I mean
like
like that's that's the interesting
that's the best you got
that's the best I mean it would have
been the argument that you keep your
money and put it in an investment that
makes more than your mortgage interest
rate yeah is at least logical and the
argument's sake this one is not even
this one's like fantasy screwed up stuff
I mean no the the number of paid for
homes that get a mortgage placed on them
um fraudulently is approaching zero it
is a very very very small thing and if
you're concerned about that type of
thing you should have Identity Theft
Protection anyway all of you have in the
states we would send you to Xander
insurance I'm not sure they issue it in
Canada but um I can't keep up with what
Canada does but the only reason I didn't
know if you're going to get into like
mortgage law or like very specific yeah
that are different fraud is fraud and so
if someone if someone's son so folks if
someone signs your name
without a power of attorney to anything
and they put your name in debt you are
not liable for that there's zero times
that you're liable for that debt yeah
how okay so how would that happen can we
just like go down that rabbit hole for a
quick second take to happen it's a very
complicated thing I mean you have to you
have to sign as if you're her
and then you have to record it at the
courthouse on her house yeah I mean it's
a complicated fraud it's very difficult
to pull off because there's about three
layers of stuff you've got to do very
clearly it's not just like a credit card
no it's very easy to do a credit card
yeah yeah I mean people do credit card
fraud all the time but right the the
mortgage oh look point eight three
percent of all mortgage applicants are
fraud less than one percent yeah so
there you go Mary that's the
applications
and that's not even yeah that's fair
that's not even it was not even issued
then yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's a non-issue yeah sure it's going to
be like 0.0008 yeah that it actually
occurs right yep and so it's just it's a
non-statistical thing but if you're
worried about fraud and you should be
because there's Crooks everywhere you
should you should get identity theft
protection from xender insurance
everybody ought to have that we buy it
for all of our employees here all of our
team all their MC team members there's a
benefit of working here it's one of our
HR benefits and because we believe in it
that strongly because there's just
something all the time if you haven't
noticed or just thinking call me all the
time on my debit card and go in
somebody's in yeah which I still
appreciate you in Mexico yeah I'm down
there again but I mean it's golly it's
not so sketchy
but Dave Dave's Cabo Dave
uh I do appreciate my bank though
they're very on top of it in that sense
like I do well because it costs them
money oh yeah not you yeah that's why
they're on top of it
yes they're service oriented and that's
not it's good that they have some
service but it's it's don't you
complemented a bank well but it's it's
really not that altruistic I mean
because it's their money that's going to
be lost not yours yeah they're trying to
protect themselves by giving you service
that's the the thing and you got to keep
this amount of banks but Mary that's a
that's a thing that comes up all the
time and um
uh no I mean the the fear of this is the
internet yeah I'm just really shocked
that a banker actually came up with this
as the reason to stay in debt among all
the other possible reasons that a banker
could have given this is this guy's
really lame so I mean he's like bottom
fishing here serious but that's the way
it is and I'm glad you called Mary
there's nothing you know Rachel I've
been doing this for 30
30 almost 31 years coming up on now here
and uh it turns out that 30 years from
now when I'm not here and you're still
doing this the questions will probably
be the same
[Music]
[Laughter]